long time Today Show anchor Matt Lauer
was fired because he was caught engaging
in sexually inappropriate behavior yeah
afterwards Lauer said maybe having all
those people looking in the windows
wasn't such a great idea
[Music]
I mean it's fine to have that we've got
to watch what you're doing I gotta
behave yourself yeah exactly that's why
you've got that podium all right
the front row nose yeah
not just Matt Lauer a former Prairie
Home Companion host Garrison Keillor has
been fired by Minnesota Public Radio
over allegations of sexually
inappropriate behavior
yeah Keeler issued an apology to his
three living fans
d-did he go to each one of them's house
he wants here's one of their houses yeah
[Laughter]
why don't they make them gold miners I
don't know I didn't even I was too lazy
to give him a Minnesota axe right right
oh we understand yeah instead I went for
the audience in a tweet this morning
Donald Trump suggested that Joe
Scarborough is a murderer yeah this is a
big step up for Trump it's the first
time he's connected a crime to a white
guy - speaking of Trump - properties
associated with Donald Trump have
decided to remove his name from their
buildings sadly neither one is the White
House
former White House adviser Steve Bannon
is heading to Alabama to campaign for
and battle candidate Roy Moore to help
him out yeah yeah it's part of their
they deserve each other tour I like some
people started to your and then they saw
that no one else'll know just keeping
them warm I wasn't back Nintendo has
teamed with Kellogg's to make a Mario
Brothers cereal Mario Brothers cereal
Kellogg's promises at the Super Mario
cereal will taste like plumber looks at
that guy who says I want looks like him
right right why new study just came out
oh I do loves me my new studies a new
study finds that men with thick biceps
thick biceps are more likely to live
longer yes
the study also found that I died 10
years ago
it's not bad right
not bad you keep your hands off me
and the married man burns
I do that joke for my wife all the time
[Applause]
get to work
you